on the northeast coast of germany
looking out of the baltic sea there's a
tourist attraction
that i think is really strange four of
them actually all identical
at different seaside resorts and i think
they're strange because
they're modern the tout gondola the
diving gondola
feels like it should be some 19th
century industrial revolution invention
it's a diving bell
a chamber that sinks under the water and
lets you look out on the ocean floor
which is only a couple of meters down at
this point sure but this isn't like the
disneyland fake submarines that pretend
to die using some bubbles and lighting
tricks
this really does go underwater to me
this feels like it should be some sort
of
over complicated steam-powered thing
that would entertain rich bismarck era
royalty for a few years and then
fall into disrepair and turn up in a few
old photos of bizarre seaside
attractions
from the past but this it opened in 2009
from a diploma engineer andreas wolf
dancing
the technology here is modern and with
modern technology comes modern safety
standards this gondola has the opposite
problem to most elevators the average
tourist isn't gonna be worried that it
might
fall but they are gonna ask if it might
get stuck down there
or worse that it might uh spring a leak
[Applause]
[Music]
did not expect that just having a wave
right at your face is is
is weird as always
normal atmosphere
i didn't expect the sound i don't know
why
but i didn't expect the sound
as in advanced centimeters
class there is one slight catch of
course there's not too much usually
visible in the baltic sea it's not
crystal clear caribbean water on the
best of days
and today all those waves are churning
up the ocean bed as well
so if you're hoping that sharks or huge
schools of tropical fish would swim by
you're going to be disappointed you
might get a couple of curious flounders
or a few jellyfish passing by
the novelty is being on what is to be
fair an actual short diving expedition
without needing scuba equipment or a
wetsuit but the folks here were worried
that people might be disappointed if
they didn't see anything
so they actually close the shutters and
play a 3d film
on farm food
naturally
if the goal was see the ocean floor well
you do that without the chamber and all
the fancy mechanisms you could set down
a few big walls with thick windows in
them
pump the water out and just have a
regular viewing gallery that you could
stand in
but that's not as cool it is a little
unnerving seeing the water
rise around you out of your control and
it's
also a bit reassuring to surface again
into the sunshine
because in the end it's not about the
fish it's about the experience
you